hello and welcome to this week's
humorous look at the impending nuclear
holocaust
i'm constantine kissing and i look like
the bollywood answer to count dracula
and i'm frances foster a man who looks
like sue perkins if she gave up halfway
through transitioning in breaking news
today russia's foreign minister sergey
lavrov has confirmed that russia will
not attack other countries
that's reassuring because it did not
attack ukraine
the west's response has been swift and
impressive sanctions boycott and direct
action against prominent supporters of
uncle vlad's evil regime
nothing will wound russia's national
pride more than cancelling ads which
depict russians as insurance peddling
rodents you joke but there's more
dostoyevsky stravinsky and rachmaninoff
have all seen their works pulled simply
for the crime of being russian the
cardiff philharmonic orchestra has
cancelled tchaikovsky from their
programme that's shocking cardiff has a
philharmonic orchestra yeah i know it's
a bit like finding out that saudi arabia
has a well-attended gay pride festival
russian oligarch roman abramovich has
had his assets seized in the uk the
labour party was initially opposed to
the move but quickly relented when they
found out he's jewish chelsea football
club are now in danger of going bust
which will have a huge impact on south
london's racist community if the club
faults they could even be forced to
support west ham maybe even millwall our
thoughts and prayers are with all racist
hooligans at this difficult time hashtag
stamp with racism like any crisis the
war has impacted some of the most
vulnerable people in society yes many
influencers have been forced to find
ukraine on a map before giving their hot
take on the situation but let's look at
the real heroes of the ukraine crisis
that's right it's all the fat lads
chaining themselves to mcdonald's in
russia in a desperate bid to stop them
leaving finally a genuine activist no
hashtags no flags just total dedication
to heart disease and diabetes despite
his efforts mcdonald's facebook
instagram and twitter have all ended
their russian operations making the
country one of the healthiest places to
live in the entire world well apart from
that whole freedom of speech thing i
mean it's not as if twitter or facebook
believe in that either but we shouldn't
underestimate the power of corporate
giants to make a difference i can't wait
for all ways to release ukrainian themed
products
always zelensky the new sanitary towel
for when the thrill of seeing a man
defend his country just gets too much
before we go spare a thought for the
real victims of this crisis what ukrans
no
think what a sad moment this must be for
sue gray no one gives a [ __ ] about her
report anymore suddenly the fact that
boris was quaffing prosecco and stuffing
his face with dominoes whilst carrie
pushed her green agenda right up
in the middle of lockdown doesn't seem
like such a big deal does it
guys we raised nearly 55 000 pounds for
ukrainian humanitarian charities last
week if you're able please do support a
charity like the red cross ukraine
appeal or another great charity that
works in poland ukraine and other
countries in the region to help people
who are fleeing war
[Music]